bob i want you to treat this like you're
taking us on a pleasure cruise
where's the oh it's always the pres
always depends on passengers
your gun spins them around jack so you
uh
try and shoot on the ends of the ship to
spin them i feel like we're being here
i didn't know is that guy an enemy that
guy looks red to me
that guy looks at him the guy looks kind
of red i don't know
i think that's our ally oh no red's the
other team that's right yeah
that's the other team oh i would have
been shooting at him a lot more than if
i had known that
and light them up light them up light
them up that's that's what i'm doing
all right you're coming back into play
jack yeah
i can never remember which one shoot him
a lot hit him in the ass
hit him in the air
i slip into it i can't help it it just
happens get him jack
we just slip into something more yeah
their hole is down keep hitting them
keep hitting them red means
nail objects hey think of peaceful
solutions to our problems maybe it's not
always best
pursue no problem it's always best to
pursue your problems in this manner okay
we're pirates we're pirates
because we're by ourselves i'm going to
put front and right gun on them mark can
you
can you get on with the gatling yeah i
can do that
uh oh oh the red i can't aim up fast
enough god dang it yeah they went up
all right we need more elevation bob i'm
going
i'm going to try and circle around on
them funk
funk i'm bonking things for some reason
oh we got firing coming
spray everything down spray everything
all right i'm climbing jack shoot shoot
shoot
yeah shoot him jack i have to spray well
shoot first i'll spray i'm i'm watching
you oh the hole's not looking too good
i'll get the hull i hit him in the face
hit him in the face i really have one
person on a gun
well yeah we only got one gun in the
front what do you expect our teammate
firing us no that is someone else okay
is everything i can't turn i can't damn
it can't hit
oh [ __ ] i keep getting stuck on like the
the everything here
i'm gonna burn uh get on engines i'm
burning okay we're running away because
our teammates are all dead
looking out for that ass why are they
dead
i don't know we're the only blue people
alive right now well we should have
gotten the spire but
we like that's a problem with the
goldfish it only has one gun in the
front and it can only shoot like one
gun at a time i should have gone galleon
all right we escaped them
our teammates should be flanking them it
looks like
so i'm going to come around and we'll
engage the steel butterfly again okay
yeah okay main engines almost fixed i
can
promise you that they're never going to
burn up our hull like that's never going
to happen
that's never going to happen is that a
promise you can make mark yeah i just
made it
what you don't believe me but you want
me to go irish on you
do it i can't all right shoot him up
jackie
there's no time for sass wade we're
shooting things oh sweet jesus
i immune to the hull suddenly it's on
fire god damn that's stupid this is
stupid
i don't like this damn jack get on the
gatling gun and shoot him
all right we're going to need a fire
extinguisher down here on the hall
come in because it's bad
get it next time up no it's going down
get ready to repair uh
okay yeah we're in trouble huh here we
go yeah i got it i got it i got it
oh god
all right never mind i'll go on the
bottom engines i'll get one up
don't get me wrong it's a small fraction
of window to be able to hit them
yeah that's why like that's why i was
saying like the main gun you don't need
main guns
main guns kind of suck all right jacks
oh they're right here
yeah jack went down hold down i'm going
i'm going
we're in trouble dang it our gun is down
all right i'm trying to fix these
engines so we can run away hit him jack
hit him jack
i'm hitting him all right get him with
that mallet okay you got it
okay there you go there you go hang on
keep turning them keep turning i feel
like this is not going well oh that's
fine
we're good we're good we're good i just
dropped the fire proof on the hall
that's what i did wrong thank you
hey i'm turning them again get away from
our [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah good work good
work
we're retreating we're not gonna
get on the gatling and hit him up all
right we'll soon just let me
make sure this is cool oh yeah jack got
it get this we have three
three and uh friendlies over here
flanking them oh they're dead they're
dead
so that we don't get totally screwed
again i can't believe we're not dead
paul buffed because it's because we're
awesome
you see bird of prey on the right jack
yeah i'm going to go around
our team our teammates are going to
engage him from the front we're going to
go around behind
them from when i can't yeah yeah are you
use that head
heavy clip is real all right i'm going
to turn on
them front gun jack front gun
right now about how to repair thing
get rid of that oh good shot good shot
good shot
keep going this is fun oh they're going
down they're going down
go go down all right keeping you nice
and upgraded and also very cool
thank you sir thank you max i feel so
cool and relaxed
i know that's like my job and i did it
well you did it
an engine is damaged on your screen oh
no
all right good good kill boys how do i
get rid of this i'm gonna stick we're
flying in a huge formation right here
i'm gonna stick with our team yeah we
gotta stick with
each other or else we'll we'll be torn
apart that's the problem the other team
for as good as they are
they don't work well together they have
a lot of opinions you gotta stick with
your people there's egos there
there's there's cooled on those engines
here
i'm repairing them now you might need it
way don't don't dismiss it before you
try it you are pretty terrible
now that we're just gonna all right
every time anything is damaged it takes
up half my screen telling me
get ready front guns uh
yeah i'm gonna try and drop in on them
here whenever you use something that
damages the engines definitely tell me
ahead of time oh does my foot thing
damage the engine yes it does sorry
sorry turning engines is what it is i
kept thinking that i that was not
damaging things but that's stupid i
i [ __ ] i'm bad at this gun okay we
got bird of prey coming in on the right
these guys are trying to see okay that
spire is gonna go down
yeah are we are you going front guns oh
god oh god
okay they're right here inspired focus
on inspired turn them around
okay keep that remember to keep
everything sprayed down
otherwise because they they like their
fire berta prey is sneaking up our ass
but
yeah well we're going to go over them
and then our teammates hopefully will
help hopefully
theoretically so we're gonna drop down
engage engage bird of prey
gotcha watching the engines spin them
around oh
big damage it's okay hit that mallet
yeah damn it keep missing
you can do it check this out there you
go there you go come on reload faster
please
all right flip them around there jackie
oh god oh oh we took a big hit to the
hull someone's smacking us bad
yeah okay we're in trouble
yeah we're getting we're getting focused
right now it's all right
i'm gonna run towards our team it's
about to go down just help me repair it
okay
it's just a really dumb decision when
you're repairing items oh you hit it
with your malinex bam okay good all
right cool
go back i really don't need this
tutorial
all right yeah if we want to fight we
can start fighting again we've got a
teammate here
yeah jack stay on the get on the jack
we got people firing us so deck uh left
gun yeah hit him up hit him up that
spray on
i'm gonna go around behind our teammates
oh here i'll bring you around on the
front gun in a second keep firing on the
left though
all right all right hole might go down
but keep it up
uh three-dimensionally when you're
trying to do evasive maneuvers
yeah well i just stuck underneath them
but uh we're currently flanked like
crazy
uh mark if you can get on the right gun
yeah i can get on there but the hull is
taking a beating okay balloons on fire
all right well we're going to run we're
going to run yeah brian
option because if they keep chasing us
then one of our guys can
shove up their bum bum yeah they're one
of our guys that's not able to listen to
us all right
deferred all right inspired is chasing
us
uh if someone could get on the right gun
if you have time uh they're gonna be on
the right guy i'll get it i'll get it
jack you focus
on oh which one oh inspired
yeah inspired go for hole shots try and
down their guns or go for them
i'm gonna pop their balloon because the
balloon is so big someone else watch
hull
i think we're actually getting away from
them so this is this is working out yeah
if i can drop their balloon they'll fall
and maybe hit one of the
buildings [ __ ] i'm not doing that
they're just not there
i'm working on it we're running there
where why isn't anyone spraying things
he just fixed it all right front gun
front gun jack
go jack bird of prey right in front of
us
hit him hit him hit him i'll bring you
on target
yeah good work good work at work okay
upgrading you jack ah waiting
for the [ __ ] reload no bad time bad
touch
where are our friends why do our friends
keep dying
i don't know because they're awesome and
they're not oh we haven't died yet
looks like yeah we're flying is that a
huacha hitting us
uh yeah what what is uh the mini missile
yeah of course many many many we're
gonna go we're gonna go under steel
butterfly
and uh engage bird of prey yes bird of
prey is attacking our ally
inspired's chasing us but we're faster
than him so yeah we're way faster than
him so that should be fine
okay get ready i'm gonna come i'm gonna
come back
[ __ ] him up [ __ ] him up i'll try and
stay out of range of that fire
yeah okay yeah that's a huacha i know a
you got it inspired still looking at us
funny
uh yeah he's not doing a lot of damage
i'm gonna go underneath inspired again
because he's slow as [ __ ] i hit him so
he's spinning oh please go down please
go down ship
oh my god hopefully oh sweet jesus okay
he moves back
quick okay balloon's on fire he's all
right now
or he's behind us i i mix up my fronts
and my backs
i'm uh i boosted the engines in the back
hopefully that makes
him get away from him
yeah focus on steel butterfly if he's if
he's in trouble focusing down
yeah because we can run away from the
other guys they'll never be able to
touch us
they'll never find us they'll never know
what he's
fired we're running away from inspired
right now they're gonna be isolated once
we take out one of these red guys we
should turn on them
yeah but let's make sure oh
going for the engine i'm going for back
engines yeah come on hit him hit him you
can do it jackie
yeah all right all right all right
all right he's going to be on the nose
in like two seconds
no bird of prey bird afraid because he's
attacking our ally we can run away from
inspired
okay i'm upgrading you again jack come
on hit him
almost come on there you'll be upgraded
thank you oh whoa whoa whoa i don't know
how he did that we're gonna have to go
over a mark i'm gonna burn turning
engines in like
10 seconds let me uh get some hits on
inspired here
hit him yeah i need him
is he out of range all right burning
turning energy
going back
this is fun we have a good team well we
got a good [ __ ]
our team i don't know keep picking him
jackie keep hitting him
spin him facing towards us is bad keep
spinning
he's coming he's coming uh yeah ouch
ouch ouch ouch ouch oh god that watch it
hurts
holy [ __ ] balls all right we're running
past uh gatling's gonna have shots on
him
he's on the hole go jack go go go go
shoot him up shoot him up jack shoot him
up
yeah okay i need to stay on the whoa i
get turned around
quit flaming my balloon we'll try and
keep you off that's i told you you
should have had the chemical spray
told me to stick with the fire
extinguisher do that birds of prey get
them
i'll keep on inspire guys shaking like
yeah we got hit hard we're getting
getting lots of damage
i can't hit him anymore he's going too
low all right hang on all right i'm
going to have him dropping
oh he's going to go under us we're going
to have to run we're running okay
running running running run run run run
run jesus i'm running
running back to our team our team is not
doing well
we haven't died yet i'm surprised
haven't yet
i'm not a particularly great pilot but
well this is a particularly great we're
half coordinated that's that's
part of the all right i'm gonna swing
around and we'll fly in formation with
our teammates
uh inspired is right on our ass if we
could do some damage to his guns or
something
uh well that's the problem with this
ship no back guns
all right yeah i fired this thing but
it's kind of [ __ ] good work jack good
work
thank you oh hi inspired how are you
doing yeah he's like right there
oh he's facing away though no he's
always facing us
okay okay right there as well
i can hear angry
we're gonna hide behind our spire
that'll help yes do that
use our teammates as a meat shield maybe
that's why we're not we should probably
turn around
okay we're going we're going we're going
we're good
oh inspire just went down six six six
six yeah let's help our team kill the
other one
all right steal steal butterfly jack get
him jack
i i'm too far away i i'm going i'm going
all right full speed ahead i'm gonna
burn what you need
burning uh driving engine oh i hit him
i'm hitting the go fast button
there we go you gotta go fast you go
fast all right drag what i can too
hit him hit him he's still spotted
though
yeah just aim for the target it's hard
oh it's hard
it's hard yes it's first hard place
oh jesus our teammate is maneuvering in
front of us
oh god all right i'm gonna die
i'm gonna not charge in and we're gonna
wait yeah yeah they're
they're gonna be regrouping if we look
at the map
yeah we yeah we're off we're all in one
corner so just
stick with our team we got one off to
the right
that's our spire he'll come up one in
front of us yeah we're good
is it like the first ten or something i
don't know i don't know
keep everything sprayed i i say is i'm
the only one that really sprays things
i spray mine just doesn't last yeah
uh it's not your fault you have a weak
spray weight it's okay yeah
well if you don't train your muscles
yeah you gotta do them kegels
faster than you'd believe all right i
can't hold it we're making up ground on
steel butterfly we might be in range
i'm gonna shoot maybe hit him you're
gonna hit him
it never hurts to keep shooting
especially with that heavy clip
there's just there's just too much lead
on him
steel butterfly has turned to us so he
definitely
got his head yeah okay i'm gonna start
backing up
i'm turning them i'm turning them okay
focus on steel butterfly just hit them
you upgraded you're good okay hit em
hard thank you you're welcome we're
gonna
we might need to burn uh our speed
engines mark in a couple minutes oh go
for it
on this but i'll let you know oh i
thought you meant now sorry i he
was not as close as i thought hey i'm
trying to like keep him spun
in like a certain direction yeah okay
keep on him jack
we have inspired inverted prey on our
left oh yes we do we're good
break to the [ __ ] [ __ ]
you got him jack you got him i still got
lots of like
got some okay oh
that's not us
oh the game grumps cheering
i don't want to cheer
where are we going we end up killing
each other before we even find enemies
yeah we're all just gonna crash into
[ __ ]
that's okay fix the hole we haven't met
enemies there's a mountain here
oh god yeah mountains they're a thing
he said mountain a thing or two that's
fine
it makes it look cool when it gets all
scratched up yeah
yeah it gives it that antiquey look and
it decreases the resale value
yeah yeah
are we selling this when we're done
right we can for charity
hey that's another mountain
that's a party boat over there
i didn't know i didn't know it was that
kind of party man i already shouldn't
prepare bob don't you crash into the
ground it's fine it's fine
yeah the ground's fine pizza and some
mountain dew i think we can reach
oh all the flavors oh my god they have
like a super bowl commercial
is that spire over there our friend yeah
that's our friend it's weird because the
balloon's red like yeah why is he red
he painted it red like a dingus that's
what it beautiful
that's the developers this
i don't think enemies are here no they
went they went around the other way
wait is that no this is our tactic this
is our tactic we go around we're just
gonna hide from them
oh no that's a good guy yeah okay guys
has anyone spotted anyone
no no i think they're on the they're in
the middle of the map we gotta go south
into the mountains
okay you guys why is aaron the one
leading us
because you're the big ship with the big
guns and you got the party balloons
oh bad guys we're inspired inspired
inspired ahead of us
and here goes our dev ship about to blow
up already all right yeah get him jackie
hey there you go hit him hard get him
hot and then crying i'm trying give me
this
hit him use your new ability with the
explosions and the whatever
all right let's all just hover let's all
just hover here in formation
and roll the [ __ ] out of inspired
oh that is a bad day for you guys they
got both of their buddies
there too so dark day for blimp get him
get him get him get him i'm gonna back
up
all right we killed one we did it
teamwork
do you see the pyramid they're left over
there over left left left left i'm gonna
fly
oh this didn't turn to the mercury field
gun either damn it
can we come here oh who's that we're
back to guns someone hit us hard
someone's hitting us directly directly
in front of us
gatling gun gatling gun gatling gun okay
be there in a second i got to make sure
this is okay
okay we're dragging on the ground for
some reason damn it i was not able to
extinguish that
keep the fire down keep everything
sprained everything
got linked on this in range oh my god
where are you guys
we're getting spun around by this stupid
steel butterfly yeah
every time i change guns you change
they're spinning us around
jack i'm not doing this okay
what's up what's in the middle back
i i feel like our coordination has all
failed already no no no no no we're fine
keep bending them jack just remember to
keep everything sprayed like everything
has to keep sprayed
gallon gun jack i i'll get it all right
oh
i repaired it i'm gonna try to shoot
their gun
yeah take out that [ __ ] spinny gun
trying hitting as hard as i can
jackie use okay you go go
nice nice nice i'm gonna bring the
gatling back in the red they're ready
yeah
gatling gatling gatling gatling
something on fire okay if i can reload
bring it up
keep hitting them with the gatling
holding someone help i'm i'm on the hole
i'm on hold
i'll help okay hold down anyways
good shots good shots good shots okay
keep on that hole let me know if i need
to pull off this gun but i'm gonna be
right
behind us uh yeah we're completely shot
we're completely flanked but if we can
take out steel butterfly it's worth it
i don't know they went far away the
gatling
well they're not in there yeah that was
our first death our problem was going
for steel butterfly when they were
running away
we just popped yeah okay all right bob
pick a spot
burn engines to get back in there
because we need to join the fight
yeah yeah no they died oh [ __ ] look look
how damaged they are go for a bread of
prey yeah
we were ahead uh okay no we're up what
we're up one we're up one we're okay
all right good job good job guys we're
on our way earn as hard as you can
i'm burning mind those mountains now
full burn full burn
we're fine
wow good job gross done good job grips
you're proud bob mountain it must be
those
guns that oh my god oh
what are you doing to my poor hall i i
can't turn when i'm burning it turns out
turns out you burn you're blaring when
you burn
all right we're gonna come around behind
inspired here yeah rubble with yours
ready on the main gun jack go ahead jack
go jack go dad go
i think my problem was last time i
focused too much on shooting steel
butterfly i should have stayed on
repairing
okay um we need i can't i need to aim
down a bit i'm going i'm going i'm good
grumps you still alive back there
yeah they're right in front of us man
cool all right one of our ships went
down though it's four to three i know it
was four to three never mind that's
because
oh my god butterfly's right in front of
us we're fighting jesus
oh my god
but there's too many right now that's a
good lesson for life
get with them no and default you guys
are really far away are you guys on the
top of the map
yeah we're coming back we're coming back
around we just gotta circle around
yeah to the left of your ship you might
want to we see them
back down we we're being hit by them we
know oh
we feel them in our balls looking at
each other i don't know what's going on
we're going to draw them
hey we're going to draw them onto the
left side of the map they're going to
follow us
so you guys come right up the middle
there and and we'll we'll turn on them
and engage two on two
sounds good to me there's fireball
that's coming out engines engines
oh hey our spire's right here okay all
right uh
just focus on the important stuff not
the guns first
yeah okay we're still running away uh so
is our spire directly into our path
okay hammered oh hell just went down
damn we hit something
oh
just keep us alive just keep us alive
it's so hard yeah we're hitting this
very hard
we're dying oh we're dead we're getting
pushed into the mountain we're dead
that's done we're not dead we're not
dead while we're dead
all right inspired what the hell what
were they hitting us with
i don't know did you guys die
yeah we're down okay happy birthday damn
i don't know like jeez we we
we're we're off rhythm here because
they're going in they're dying and then
we're flying in right in the middle of
it and then
they all focus on us yeah this is not
going very well that's okay
yeah our ships aren't even together up
there yeah we gotta we gotta get in
there but not when everyone else dies
okay it's five and five we can do this
all right we got this
all right go team jackal might as well
skedaddle i guess we're up six to five
now
yeah okay they gotta kill so let's i'll
burn in and try and get
well yeah yeah i'll try and get in
behind them this time
yeah yeah yeah we're fighting in their
spawn territory that's the problem our
teammates should pull back
because we're fighting in their spawn
guys we got steel butterfly on us and
inspired
we're coming back
yeah good because that's it's giving
them an advantage but we only need one
more kill so we just
we cannot be that kill
if you can hear me ross pull
we're fighting in their spawn area oh
god they see us we're coming we're
coming
focus focus on that oh i see what's
happening
okay let's come around behind and let's
focus on bird of prey with our ally
that's over here okay i see i see what
you're talking about i'm looking in the
mouth
i get what you're saying what you're
putting down okay so they're ready
jackie
okay kind of what they're like going
behind them i know we're going we're
going
oh god is that another bad guy behind
them that's our friend
okay we're engaging two on one with our
friend so bird of prey
if we could just get bird of prey that's
good hit
but it's too far away i'ma going keep
trying buddy
is that an enemy no [ __ ] no
hang on yes yes that's the steel
butterfly the steel brothers
great bird of free bird afraid they're
smoking all right bird of prey get him
we crashed into something yeah butterfly
we didn't hit steel butterfly we keep
getting oh god we're leaving our dev
ship alone with steel butterflies so
they're good
just take out
thank you best i can there you go keep
hitting him keep hitting him
come
okay on side is he going to float on
back up bob so we can hit him
i'm backing i'm backing okay we got
steel butterfly coming around our our
our left right side they just repaired
their balloon
yeah hang on i'm going to hit their
balloons
keep going jackie got it uh aaron you're
moving us towards the three of them
he's almost dead his hull is almost gone
if we hit him we win
oh god where to pray oh hold on
i don't think the grumps are with us
just keep hitting them jack you're doing
it i don't think ross can hear us
because his game volume is too loud
here i got an idea mark gatling i'm
galling down bird of praise armor
and then jack will finish him okay i'm
gonna try to light him on fire
here we go oh they're hitting us hard
someone get someone watch hull
okay hopefully this will light them on
all right they are not better than us we
are marginally improved
the best part about that game was no
tutorial mm-hmm
dominar for
how did i stab it in the back of the
head
was i supposed to do that the music
stopped jack and mark went to go have
the fanfiction reenactment over there
the court
wait a minute what is higher than the
others